[Music]
I'm curious a couple of okay was how
long ago we were in Chicago about a
month and a half ago we taped a week of
shows in Chicago big Irish pirate
American population there so I taped a
piece where I did Irish stepdance
I learned it in a class I think we have
a still from that variety is that really
human is that really me you don't just
get a body like that Colin yes that's
really me oh they could never find such
a head and such a body to be melded
together even with all the advancements
of you know your corsets we're at a time
I cannot take another second official
years no there's no video it's only
still you're giving us there's no video
there is video but it actually is of me
accidentally this is a real accident
kicking one of the girls in the face
take a look at that this is proof that
there I am
[Music]
[Applause]
how much was the air settlement hey
let's hook care of it let's say she's
fine she's our man she's up and around
again is the Irish step-dancing
something that people really do in
Ireland part of the school you have to
learn it in school it's a big having big
feats not always a good thing and is it
something you do yes so you learned it
in school I did learn Irish dancing in
school for a couple of years I can't say
I enjoyed em I was taught us I don't
know if I learned it but I was told
right but it's something they'd like you
to know yeah absolutely and the Irish
language which which we all got very
lazy with the men you know years
subsequent to leaving school I really
regret it because it's such a beautiful
lyrical language but of course times the
girl were to speak ghost ugly you know
it's like six right right what's also
it's a language you can't use that often
unnecessary West of Ireland and then
right exactly it's not like you can
travel the world and no idea how many
native speakers are there are still at
home maybe and this probably very
ignorant gets slammed but somewhere
between 20,000 and 50,000 on the West of
Ireland particularly the Iron Islands
but mostly connemara and goli you know
it's a beautiful language but it almost
dead one yeah now I'm surprised that you
didn't follow up on the stuff Nancy
because you were a dancer for a while
that's how you made your living for a
little while oh I I did get paid to do
something that resembled some form of
dance possibly yeah for a while oh this
sounds embarrassing let's talk about it
yeah yeah no let's roll the tape I know
you have something no we have oh we have
a picture of you I guess you were a line
dancer for a little while let me take a
look at this and he's that I can't
whether there anyone will know that's
[Applause]
don't you have we have a picture of you
I think you absolutely actually line
dancing there you are it's it's it's
tragic when that picture there is less
embarrassing than the first one
the first one I just was I was trying to
see if I had my finger out I couldn't
tell because it was at this angle do I I
don't think I do cuz they are it would
only be slightly less cool if I had my
finger I was making a gun but you look
but you look happy you look like you
enjoyed doctor my nose line dance and I
was looking happy ish
I dunno what for eight or nine months I
earned I think I was getting 750 pound a
week for driving around in a little
minivan with a bunch of people with CMT
Country Music Television jacket on I'd
wear choker cutoff sleeves and a Stetson
hat and then I did until I couldn't look
at myself in the mirror any longer but I
don't blow the money and I was only 19
they're going to be ashamed about their
you know your it was a feeling of man
that's all it's not a judgment against
west and dancer country music right I
just was right right if I could make it
as a country-western dancer I would
right now but things on the air behind
them clear back all the day bulging on
your knees get back I could I don't
really know I know it's complicated
there's a thing I love that a lot of guy
like you do this and you do love it uh
there's a lot of that prospector that
just followed I'm golden
yeah you got a failed egg man I don't
know why ladies aren't rushing forward
right now
that was sad